Speaker 1: There's a new talking point
that's becoming very popular, and it has
to do with blaming black people for covid for low
vaccination numbers. And why not? Right. I mean,
you might as well try if you're Republicans
right now and everything's going wrong,
try blaming black people. Why not? This is Texas
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick. He was on Fox
News's Laura Ingram program. He said the reason
covid is spreading wildly in Texas is black folks,
black folks who won't get vaccinated. This
is the same Dan Patrick who earlier in the
pandemic said open everything because we got to
do it for the economy and grandma is willing to
sacrifice herself. Let's listen to him explain why
black people are to blame for coming after your
Speaker 4: state really quickly here and as a
response coming after your state, because the
increased covid numbers, hospitalizations,
deaths are up in Texas and there's a direct
assault on your governor's policies and
your state's policies. Very brave response.
Speaker 5: Yeah, well, Laura, the covid is
spreading particularly. Most of the numbers
are with the unvaccinated. And the Democrats like
to blame Republicans on that. Well, the biggest
group and most states are African-Americans who
have not been vaccinated. The last time I checked,
over 90 percent of them vote for Democrats
in their major cities and major counties.
So it's up to the Democrats to get just as said,
it's up to Republicans to try to get as many
people vaccinated. But we respect the fact that
if people don't want the vaccination, we're not
going to force it on them. That's their individual
right. But in terms of criticizing the Republicans
for this, we're encouraging people who want to
take it to take it. But they're doing nothing
for the average African-American community that
has a significant high number of unvaccinated.
Speaker 2: Now, we got a lot of talk.
Speaker 1: Now you have to be able to apply
some logic here. And what I mean by that is let's
pretend that Dan Patrick has a point here. At
least he could have a point, but it could be that
he has a point. Texas only has a 13 percent black
population, so even if a full 50 percent of black
Texans don't want to get vaccinated, that's only
six and a half percent of the total population
of Texas. But we have data about who are the most
active cohorts of the population. And the most
anti VAX group is Republicans, roughly 30 percent.
It is true that black folks in the United States,
as well as people without college degrees,
Hispanic Americans and some other groups, these
are some of the more vaccine hesitant groups.
That's true. But Republicans are the ones that
take the cake. Here's another data set from the
Kaiser Family Foundation, which finds the most
vaccinated groups are Democrats, white Democrats,
65 plus Americans, college graduates, et cetera.
Black adults are right in the middle. And
Republicans, and in particular white Republicans
are at the very, very bottom. And then in the
raw numbers, 39 percent of registered voters in
Texas are Republicans, but only 13 percent are
black people. Meanwhile, it's 45 percent of the
Texas population that hasn't even gotten one dose.
And Dan Patrick wants to blame a group that's
13 percent of the population and it's sort of
getting vaccinated at roughly the same rate as the
average Americans are. Now, if you want to see an
interesting graphic we'll put up on the screen
now, on the left is the map of vaccination in
Texas. And on the right is the map of the liberal
areas in Texas. The more left leaning areas they
match perfectly. The most vaccinated parts of
Texas are the most liberal parts of Texas. But
it's anything they can do to shift the blame. And
what they're choosing now is let's blame black
people. It's just perfect, actually, for them.
I'm not surprised that this is what they're doing.
I'm surprised it took them this long to
try it. Just blame black people. Why not?
And then meanwhile, they'll also say it's people
pouring over the border thanks to Joe Biden. It's
illegal immigrant Hispanics that are bringing the
virus. The most anti VAX groups are Republicans
and white Republicans. And that's who's
driving this at the end of the day